misc freelancer bill
now over the last few years
origin has become more known for looking
fast than many sort of actual speed take
the 300 I a ship that brags about its
extra comfy beds isn't exactly what you
want when you're looking for a racer
however all is not lost
origin has just written us an apology
letter
meet the new M 50
space the best ships gracefully dance
across its expanse the worst clumsily
clawed across its face the new m15
doesn't have time for any of that
instead it simply slices its way through
the 2944 m50 designed with one goal in
mind make the ship that will win the
next money camp the surprising thing is
origin may have just about done it
stats are an orgy of mind-bending
numbers but it comes down to two things
let's wait o power you notice that the
nose cone has grown what I can only
describe as a mustache added to
stabilize all the additional thrust but
then we tooled an updated twin hammer hm
four point three drives spew out and the
refinement doesn't stop there they've
narrowed the front fuselage move the
wing
all with the better balanced shave the
cockpit view paint out of the thinnest
it could still be a not shatter in your
face result the pure flying machine each
movement on a stick translates directly
to unadulterated throttle action welcome
back to the glory days of flying
that's all well and good but when you're
talking about a racing machine at the
end of the day you really have to well
brace it and you better to prove the EM
50s metal from the last origin ship to
actually manage a Cup win the 350 are
piloting the 350 are is galactic gears
very own two-time Cup over to mo vaccine
for the m50 an incredible man who for
some inconceivable reason has never won
a single Murray cow me this my friends
is going to be good
to push the heavy
apologetic senses
apology accepted
you